linkspartei und wie groß ist tatsächlich
die gefahr eines dritten weltkrieges zu
gast heute abend bei mir
politikwissenschaftlerin und autorin
ulrike büro sie hat sich bei corona weit
aus dem fenster gelehnt und sich jetzt
der warnung von alice schwarzer vor
einem dritten weltkrieg in folge der
waffenhilfe für die ukraine
angeschlossen anders sieht das publizist
henryk broder erhält andy schwarzer für
naiv und fordert volle härte gegen den
aggressor nzz politik redakteur
alexander kissler ist alice schwarzer
dankbar dass sie eine debatte angestoßen
hat frauke petry die frühere
fdp-vorsitzende kritisiert schwarzers
brief scharf und sagt putin lässt sich
nur mit schwerem waffeneinsatz stopp
frau wo ich möchte direkt mit ihnen dann
intelligent intellektuelle wie
intelligent sind sie auch über
intellektuelle wie alice schwarzer ranga
yogeshwar oder dieter nuhr haben diesen
brief geschickt ein herrn scholz und sie
haben auch getwittert dass sie den brief
vollumfänglich unterstützen glauben sie
denn nicht dass das mädel ist also erst
mal ich ihnen da unterschrieben wie
weitere 170 tausend unterzeichner das
ist ja wirklich sozusagen richtig nach
oben gegangen ich glaube tatsächlich
dass der brief eine welle ausgelöst hat
und ich stehe voll umfänglich zu dem
brief wie ich getwittert habe warum weil
wenn wir auf dieses leid gucken von
mario pohl den krankenhäusern wirtschaft
und so weiter dann kann ich nur sagen
cicero der ungerechteste frieden ist
besser als der gerechteste krieg ja und
wenn wir uns jetzt um dieses leid
bemühen diese bilder nicht haben wollen
dann müssen wir frieden machen frieden
machen trieben machen und damit anfangen
jede eskalation ist unvertretbar allein
die tatsache dass zum beispiel gabor
steingart heute morgen im prinzip einer
eskalation und auch eine nukleare
eskalation für kontrollierbar hält das
scheint mir so hanebüchen so absurd als
könnte man eine eskalation sozusagen
jetzt schon kontrolliert irgendwie
einpreisen dass ich nur sagen kann wie
viel leid wollen wir eigentlich noch
hoch skalieren um endlich frieden zu
machen und das ist die position glaube
ich dass brief ist und wir sollten nicht
übersehen und das hat der brief jahr
deutlich herausgearbeitet dass wenn wir
jetzt schwere waffen liefern dann ist
das auch noch völkerrecht wenn wir dann
auch noch ausbildung zu lassen an diesen
waffen de facto auch völkerrechtlich
sehr sehr strittig ob das nicht
tatsächlich dann auch ein grund wäre uns
eine motivation zu unterstellen dass wir
kriegsteilnehmer werden darum geht ja
die völkerrechtliche debatte das heißt
wir sollten alles tun von westlicher
seite wenn wir den frieden wollen dann
sollten wir alles tun motive zu geben
und man das bedeutet die ukraine soll
sich ergeben ergeben also die frage ist
ja das habe ich glaube schon der letzten
sendung gesagt bei ihnen vor drei wochen
das mir ist ja überhaupt kann nicht klar
was sind denn überhaupt sozusagen die
westlichen ziele für die ukraine ja also
wenn wir jetzt mal ansetzen zusagen
territoriale integrität der ukraine
ukraine in die eu ukraine in die nato
dann sind das völlig unrealistische
ziele also die ukraine hat selten eine
territoriale integrität gehabt die
verhandlungen in die eu wurden 2014 de
facto von ukrainischer seite nicht
angenommen das heißt wir müssen uns doch
mal überlegen was ist eigentlich das
strategische ziel was wir erreichen
wollen wofür wir jetzt eine eskalation
bereits in kauf zu nehmen sind das
scheint mir überhaupt nicht klar und ich
glaube wenn wir uns mal genau angucken
wo wir ich sage nochmal cicero der
ungerechteste frieden ist besser als die
gerechteste krieg wenn wir sagen wir
wollen den frieden dann machen wir den
morgen dann sagen wir verhandlungen dann
hört das geschlachtete auf in butter und
dann wird es auf in mario pohl aber mit
schweren waffen und mit eskalation und
mit atomar werden wir im prinzip einen
einem eine martialisch strategie fahren
von der ich gar nicht weiß ja
irgendjemand vor augen hat was das
bedeutet hier holen wir einmal frau
petri rein wenn sie jetzt frau genauso
zu hören sehen sie auch die gefahr eines
dritten weltkrieges und sollten wir
aufhören schwere waffen in die ukraine
zu liefern den wunsch dass frieden den
kann ich verstehen den teilen war ich
glaube dass da sind wir uns auch gar
eigentlich an diesem tisch und nicht nur
diesen tisch aber das was sie gerade
gesagt haben wir machen fliehen und
verhandeln das ist doch völlig
realitätsfern putin wird so nicht
verhandeln wir verstehen gar nicht wie
er tickt für ihn gibt es nur sieg oder
niederlage für ihn gibt es auch keine
verhandlungs partner auf augenhöhe mit
events gehört er sich gar nicht treffen
das heißt wenn wir frieden wollen wenn
wir für die ukraine eine erträgliche
situation wollen ist die erste frage zu
stellen haben wer entscheidet was die
ukraine will ich glaube nicht dass wir
das entscheidende für thun als deutsche
und europäer gut daran die ukraine an
diese entscheidung selbst überlassen und
wie viele opfer sie bringen wollen
können auch nicht wir für sie
entscheiden wir können nur entscheiden
helfen wir die überfallenen was nicht
heißt dass sie mit allen dingen die
ukraine tut oder auch getan hat in der
vergangenheit einverstanden sein müssen
aber jetzt gibt es nur die frage kam
oder kapitulation es gibt keine
verhandlungen es gibt momentan auch
keinen frieden mit putin putin wird
diesen mut zustimmen wenn eine lage
gebracht wird in der für ihn ersichtlich
wird dass er ist nur noch mit noch
größerem aufwand und noch größeren
aufwand gebieten kann das ist nicht
schön aber schön geht es nicht aber das
ist kriegerische realität ob wir wollen
oder nicht aber was ist denn das ziel
ist das ziel dass wir sozusagen einen
feldzug gegen putin und russland führen
dass wir den krieg gewinnen aber wenn
ich auch sogar auf militärs sagen dass
krieg nicht
entweder reden wir jetzt darüber dass
wir das gemetzel in butter und mario
pohl nicht mehr sehen wollen und dann
reden wir darüber wie
das fernsehen einfach außer an sie heran
zu gehen kann doch die ukraine was sie
wollen aber was wollen die luft fangen
wir doch damals anja 2014 zum beispiel
gab es ja wenn jetzt in zwei jahren aber
es ist ja schon wichtiger zu
kontextualisierung ja gesagt zur
aktualisierung ukraine in die eu ist ja
eine dieser forderung die im raum steht
2014 gab es das angebot von wem wurde
das abgelehnt die sind erinnern warum
etwa weil die unheimlichen gesprächen
sind die russen die das sehe ich alle
nach einer nach einer ausrede
wunderbare edle ziele haben frau aber in
dem fall würde ich sagen müssen sich
eigentlich an putin richten es ist eine
absolute obszönität die sich aufhören an
die opfer einer attacke zu appellieren
sich zu ergeben
damit der aggressor bestimmter grenzen
ein sie haben offenbar keine ahnung von
putin und wenn sie jetzt mit der
ukrainischen geschichte anfangen der
kleine ist seit einer weile ist
souveräner staat es ist kein deutsches
generalübernehmer und es ist keine
aufgabe deutscher intellektueller so
sagen was die ukraine sollen und was sie
nicht dürfen das hat ja der brief war
gar nicht getaucht er genau die leute
sagen
der ukraine die sollen selbstmord
begehen weil sie nach dem essen nach ihm
sehen sein das geht einfach nicht
trennen sondern hatte ich keinen lesen
aber eher oder hier eine kurze rückfrage
nur ein herr bruder der brief sagt ja
nur eigentlich dass die intellektuellen
auch angst haben wie ranga yogeshwar
oder lied schwarzer oder auch urige das
ist halt zu einem dritten weltkrieg
führen könnte ja ok dazu ist diese ja
denn die gefahr gibt es immer völlig
unabhängig davon was gerade in der
ukraine passiert zumal mit putin aber er
ist größer geworden ich glaube wenn die
feste größe geworden ist größer geworden
ist nur ihre angst und ihre anpassung
eines zur resignation zusammen was sie
machen sollen sie haben offenbar sehr
wenig mitleid mit den opfern also sie
habe mitleid mit sich selber wusste dass
ich besser hören weil ich sage wenn wir
diese krieg und das habe ich eben
dreimal gesagt wenn wir das beenden
wollen dann reden wir das ist dem westen
dass wir es gab verhandlungen in der
türkei erdogan hat das versuche ich sage
nochmal die europäische
strategie war immer mehr den frieden bin
ich nicht will muss verhandeln dass er
das musste aber sie fahren wollen müssen
sie nicht wer alles bei putin vor
getarnt ist das schon vergessen habe ich
nichts außer ihnen waren alle
bedeutenden leute da ich bin ja nicht
bedeuten der märz ist jetzt gerade da wo
man guckt nur mit der zurück kommt ja
und ich sage nochmal wer den krieg nicht
will muss den frieden wollen und es wird
zu viel geredet über den korridor in
luft das ist kein bauernkalender sprung
in einer alexander kissler ganz kurz
noch mal rein damit wir alle standpunkte
einmal gehört haben herr kessler sie
finden ja gut dass alice schwarzer diese
debatte angestoßen hat gemeinsam mit den
anderen natürlich frau gehört eben
erwähnt wie viele schon unterzeichnet
haben wo sehen sie denn die lösung oder
wo befinden sie sich jetzt hier in dem
unterschiedlichen meinungsspektrum er
ist ein unterschiedliches
meinungsspektrum das ist schon mal sehr
wichtig dass sie das sagen wir reden
über unterschiedliche meinungen und wenn
man über meinungen unterschiedliche art
rede das ist schon mal besser als wenn
man sich die köpfe einschlägt man sieht
auch jetzt an der erhitzt zeit jetzt
gleich parat ich gewissermaßen
explodiert
wie dünn doch die zündschnur wie kurz
die 50 geworden ist und mich erinnern
dass teilweise ich will vor ihrer frage
mich nicht drücken aber mich hat die art
und weise wie wir eben debattieren
dieser ganzen debatte teilweise an
verwundungen die wir uns gegenseitig
zugefügt haben in der korona debatte
zwei jahre lang ging es auch um angst da
gab es eine gute angst angst vor corona
die dann gewisse verhaltensmaßregeln
nahegelegt hat teilweise staatlich
aufoktroyiert es gab eine schlechte
angst die angst vor der impfung es gab
leute die gute argumente hatten es gab
leute die schlechte argumente hatten und
meinungen die vom mainstream oder von
einer mehrheitsmeinung abwichen wurden
lange nicht als abweichende meinung
gesehen sondern als moralische effekte
dessen der diese abweichende meinungen
äußert das ist glaube ich eine lehre aus
krone und wir reden teilweise
ansatzweise ja auch schon in der ukraine
frage als hätten wir nichts gelernt oder
als wären wir nicht in der lage etwas zu
lernen aus diesen debatten wir tauschen
hier meinungen aus wir müssen die texte
dann wirklich schon ganz genau lesen ich
habe es auch kritische anfragen an
diesen text gar keine frage aber wir
müssen glaube ich die meinung von dem
stärker trennen der sie äußert schreibt
mir die wichtigste lehre zu sein aus der
krone debatte die meinung von dem
trennen der sie äußert ich muss ihnen
ehrlich sagen das ist jetzt eine debatte
da kann ich das lineal anlegen wo ich
will und ich bekomme keine geradeheraus
muss ich ganz klar sagen ich bin
selbstverständlich auch für frieden ich
bin aber auch sehr dafür dass er putin
diesen krieg nicht gewinnt ich bin sehr
dafür dass wir der ukraine nicht sagen
welche ziele sie zu erreichen hat ich
bin aber auch sehr dafür dass wir nicht
sagen wir müssen jetzt fünf sechs sieben
jahre lang die aller schärfsten waffen
die wir haben permanent ohne ansehen der
jeweiligen situation in die ukraine
senden das heißt ich bin wirklich für
eine abrüstung auch in der debatte dass
wir uns mehr in diesen positionen aber
ich muss wirklich sagen mich an inters
etwas an die situation die kennen sie
bestimmt alle im golf von korinth da
gab's killer und charybdis zwei
meeresungeheuer und wettermann ist links
vorbei woltmann aufgefressen oder man
ist vorbei und wurde aufgefressen man
kam nicht richtig durch und meine sorge
ist ein wenig dass wir uns hier in
dieser debatte in der wir wirklich nur
ein einfaches zeichen meinungen
austauschen und den kopf so einschlagen
als könnten wir hier am tisch wirklich
diese verfahrene situation genau klären
das wäre ein wichtiger appell lasst uns
wirklich verbal auch abrüsten und
schauen was eine position ist die wir
vor unserem eigenen gewissen seinem
gewissen und unserem eigenen wissen auch
fahren da würde ich diese debatte ist
wie alle meinungen die in deutschland
geäußert werden für den verlauf des
krieges in dem kleine völlig irrelevant
ist ein argument mehr
werden zivilisten oder abrüsten spielt
für den ausgang der geschichte keine
aber vielleicht trotzdem wir werden eine
erkenntnis selber angehört und fall von
bestialität zu dir keiner vor einem
krieg dafür eine seite ausfüllen und mit
leuten die offenbar gerne wird die tisan
gerne politik machen möchte ich würde
die reihe ist vielleicht in der
angefragten verzeihung dass dass ich
nochmal direkt auf diesen diesen brief
eingehe den text haben wir jetzt nicht
vor uns aber manch ein zuschauer hat
ihnen vielleicht vor seinem geistigen
auge und das was mich daran einerseits
massiv stört und zum anderen auch ein
bisschen freut ist folgendes der text
ist voller widersprüche das ist nicht
schlimm war menschen häufig voller
widersprüche sind er wünscht sich etwas
und den wunsch können wir alle verstehen
aber ich kann nämlich auf der einen
seite mir frieden wünschen und übersehen
dass in diesem fall den frieden dem man
sich auf die art und weise wünscht
bedeutet dass man diesen aggressor und
damit faktisch auch andere aggressoren
von denen es ja auf der welt noch viel
mehr gibt denken sie an nordkorea denken
sie an china denken sie an den iran das
sind alles länder die atomwaffen haben
ja dass man wie weit wird putin entgehen
dass man diesen leuten es gibt erstens
zeigt dass man auch in dieser
aggressoren sendet das mal erlauben um
den ländern überfallen werden und es
gibt andere kandidaten die angst davor
haben müssen eine ähnliche schicksal zu
erleiden wenn ich mir einen taiwan oder
an südkorea denken dass man jetzt im
grunde mit einer derartigen politiker
wäre daran erinnert haben sie weiter für
ihr können am ende nichts machen wenn
die aggression nur groß und die drohung
groß genug ist nämlich die drogen
mithalten sagt haben wir als west nicht
mehr zu vermelden so und das ist eine
daraus eine warten sie ganz kurz vor
augen sie wollen das gute das glaube ich
tatsächlich nicht ausklammern in ordnung
ist das dürfen sie auch nicht glaube ich
glaube aber ich glaube sogar dass wie
dieter nuhr ein mutiger mann reinhard
mey und viele andere die auch erst
unterzeichnet haben dass sie das gute
wollen aber übersehen dass man das gute
nicht immer dadurch erreicht dass man
zurück wir diesen tag ist der kampf oder
kapitulation für die ukraine und
kapitulation finde ich ist auch aus
unserer sicht kein
allein das frame im kampf oder
kapitulation für fehlgeleitet ich bin
ganz bei herrn kessler ich krieg auch
keine gerade linie solange hier nicht
definiert wird was das überhaupt heißen
soll anführungsstriche den krieg
gewinnen ja da ist nicht klar wollen wir
oder wollen vielleicht der amerikaner
regime change wollen wir also putin weg
haben oder wollen wir putin noch da
lassen aber erreichen dass putin die
ukraine immer nur sein
das lineal ist nicht gerade keiner
kriegt hier eine linie aber dass wir
noch nicht mal darüber nachdenken was
das denn anführungsstriche ich sage es
noch mal heißen soll den krieg zu
gewinnen und dass wir deswegen
dass wir eine ich sage es nochmal de
facto eskalationsspirale zu lassen die
wir ja nachgerade herbeireden ja also
wenn sie heute die nachrichten an machen
dann der dritte weltkrieg ich weiß nicht
wie auch das wort schon gefallen ist der
dritte weltkrieg ist jetzt beherrscht
bei usw ich möchte nur noch mal dran
erinnern als wir 1914 kriegskredite
bewilligt haben waren wenige jahre
später 20 millionen menschen auf diesem
kontinent tod verstümmelt verhungert usw
danach gab es inflation hyperinflation
und den faschismus und ich habe ja ich
habe ich weiß nicht ob wir heute ein
besseres instrumentarium haben um in der
gleichen eskalationsspirale zu sagen ach
das haben wir uns nicht so gedacht weil
wir haben wir daher
dieser logik können sie alles begründen
ja sagt dem ersten krieg alles war meine
logik ist eine andere wenn man hitler
rechtzeitiger arm gefallen wäre werden
viele opfer nicht nötig gewesen es kann
auf den zeitpunkt gekommen und 20
millionen russischer soldat ich habe um
das
nicht ich weiß ich weiß ja dass die
toten statistik an dieser stelle soll
weil das was sie fordern wird mehr tote
und mehr opfer nach sich ziehen sie
wollen nicht eine reduktion der toten
sie wollen das absolut gewinnen die
waffen die waffen so genannte waren
neben
oder auf den alliierten zugerufen nach
der landung in der normandie die waffen
nieder hätten sie das gemacht das war
auch eine eskalation des krieges die
waffen nieder ist nie was
milchmädchen überlegen aber das ist ein
zeichen von äpfel und birnen
nur noch ein satz hören sind die
gleichen formationen die gleiche
argumentation vertreten wenn nicht die
drohung mit atomwaffen raum stünde wenn
das ein rein konventioneller krieg werde
aber das sind nach dem krieg stilen
unseren fragen meine sind das nicht ich
kann ihnen genau sagen was das
kriegsziel ist und wenn der krieg mit
einem schlag beendet werden wenn die
russen hinter die alle die hinter die
russisch ukrainischen grenze sich
zurückziehen dann ist der krieg vorbei
die ukraine hat keine territorialen
forderungen an die sowjetunion des
elsass das können sie tatsächlich wenn
sie ihn deswegen noch mal ein bisschen
kontext realisieren der es gab einen in
der ukrainischen krieg
wichtig wir können doch jetzt nicht auch
so tun als wenn sozusagen provokation
das wort ist eine provokation
ich habe mich nicht mehr beherrschen
können wie sie sehr gut können wir ein
bisschen geschichte mitdenken und dann
einfach mal davon ausgehen dass dieser
krieg nicht am 25 februar
2022 begonnen hat sondern eine lange
vorgeschichte halle sondern
vorgeschichte und war gesorgt ist
logisch ich liebe das heißt wenn sie
sagen vorgeschichte sogar euro gehen die
vorgeschichte ist und sie julia
timoschenko die vorgeschichte ist
vielfältig was ich nur sagen gerade
diese vorgeschichte ist acht jahre alt
der krieg in der ukraine er hat acht
jahren gedruckt bevor putin über die
grenze ist ich negieren hat sich hansa
sucht ihn der aggressor ist sich negiere
mitnichten dass es ein angriffskrieg ist
ich sage nur zu sagen das ist eine
territoriale integrität in das war auch
schon vorher nicht der fall don't ask
lohans usw
natürlich ist die ukraine ein souveräner
staat und hat trotzdem acht jahre
gebiets konflikte in ihrem eigenen staat
gab das ist genauso als wenn wir
sozusagen zwischen bayern und dem rest
ja ich glaube doch statt mit gebiets
kommando überfall nein das was ich sage
ist ich möchte den frieden sofort die
waffen nieder wenn wir weiter eskalieren
wird das ein drama und wir werden viel
mehr menschen rufen sagen putin zu die
waffen nieder wusstest du dieser pose
ich mag ihr definieren was überhaupt
unsere ziele sind und unsere ziele an
für die wir sehen wie viel gewinnen
das müssen wir definieren deswegen herr
kessler wo ist eigentlich das gerade
lineal jedenfalls so sagen dass die
ukraine ein sozusagen demokratischer
ungeteilter
perfekter start war vor dass
ich hoffe ja gerade schulden ab doch
keine so gar kein vergleich mit einem
vergleich her gerade ist auch ob die
ukraine ein perfekter start ist im
verein könnte also lauten einig und
betrügen ein nach hilft er sie trotzdem
den überfall natürlich da ich möchte
ihnen nicht über farbe sie haben genau
das kind hat ganz haben das ist kein
perfekter start natur ist perfekter
stationen sind auch keine perfekte
akademie
niemand ist perfekt ja und trotzdem
möchte ich noch mal sagen wir tun so als
wenn wir hier die
vorgeschichte nicht mitdenken könnten
darum gegen müssens ghana so mussten
gute finalisieren
sie wollen auch ein seminar oder ein
ziel hier vor gericht ist nicht leicht
ich kann er dabei auch gleich mal
beliebt seien aber hallo aber das wird
schwer aber
wir können nicht ständig sagen in die
vorgeschichte rechtfertigt im grunde gar
nicht erst trainer sich verteidigen die
für das hier ist nicht wichtig wer
verantwortung des valley copper gold
rente und dann müssten wir bereits jetzt
ist egal was wir können noch besser auf
den punkt der diskussion heute abend
zurück denn erst so der deutsche it
branche schon viele kleine geschäft ist
wurde nicht gefordert von den deutschen
intellektuellen die ukraine soll die
waffen niederlegen es wurde nur
appelliert an die bundesregierung an die
deutsche bundesregierung
sondern die russen und komba entspricht
dann möchte ich darauf hinweisen aber
wir müssen ja ist auch subtile
botschaften zwischen den zwei wissen ja
frau schwarzer und co schon ehrlich hier
in der runde sagen was sie gefordert
haben und sie haben nicht gefordert
gelegen die waffe sagt das ist die
conclusio dieses briefes die ukraine
sollen aufhören sich zu verteidigen
ich komme damit opferfamilie ging es
darum die rolle von deutschland die
conclusio des briefes ist es dass eine
kleine population ließ es der partei
lange vermuten dass diese motivation
dann dazu führt dass wenn es eskaliert
wie eine mitverantwortung an der
eskalation haben und dass durch die
eskalation vielmehr tot wir haben auch
in der
73 die können sie gar nicht mehr haben
frau gerächt
ich muss das gar nicht beweisen weil ich
die hypothese nicht aufstelle aber sie
nehmen doch
letztlich an dass wenn der krieg jetzt
beendet wird die ukraine besser dran ist
das war erst erstes ich habe alles
irgendwie richter frieden ist immer
besser als der krieg und da
widersprechen ganz entschieden ja in dem
fall passiert ist nicht mehr über sich
nicht
widersprechen weil ich sage was wissen
wir denn was in der ukraine folgt was
haben denn die russen damals empfohlen
gemacht mit der führungsriege 20011
athen und was wir wissen wir überhaupt
also es ist doch jetzt schon klar dass
die russen kein interesse daran haben
die ukraine oder was die ukraine einmal
war als ein halbwegs zu dieses gebilde
bestehen zu lassen es geht am ende ganz
brutal um die auswirkung dieser relativ
jungen nation entweder durch flucht und
vertreibung oder durch politisch und
ethnische säuberung weil sonst das
gebiet für die russen gar nicht
beherrschbar ist das heißt das einfach
auszublenden was passiert in dieser
krieg jetzt beendet wird weil das heißt
dass die ukraine kapitulieren muss und
ja ich bleibe dabei derzeit ist ist nur
kampf oder kapitulation für die ukraine
und wenn die ukraine
zwischenfrage allianz kurzer und
wichtige zwischenfrage ist es denn
möglich dass die ukraine gewinnt über
russland in den augen naja was heißt
denn gewinnen in diesem krieg da gebe
ich ihnen sogar eher wenig über die kaje
oder ihr reihe müssen die tun als
prüfung so krainer diejenigen
was heißt die demokratie sondern auch
ein hockeyspiel was da stattfindet
natürlich nicht sagen kann und ihm
überall ist es auch durchaus von
diversen klugen leuten auch in diesem
land schon aufgegriffen worden die
ukraine haben schon mehrfach punkte
definiert was ist für sie heißen könnte
ob es um die frage einer nato
mitgliedschaft in der eu mitgliedschaft
ging ob es um die frage der
unabhängigkeit des donners team und den
trainer posten aber auch die liegt die
krim frage ja dort hatte es sozusagen
angebote gegeben aber es gibt von putin
spätestens seit dem vorfall die überfall
und den versenkung des kriegsschiffes
gibt es von putin keine
verhandlungsbereit auf keiner ebene mehr
das heißt noch einmal es sind nicht die
ukraine nicht bereit wären zu verhandeln
putin ist es derzeit nicht das heißt das
einzige ziel so bitter wie das für alle
beteiligten ist die russen eine lage zu
bringen in der man am ende beiden seiten
die putin den russen und den ski der
ukraine einen wie auch immer gearteten
kompromiss verkaufen kann das war es
wird kampfhandlungen geben zu glauben
dass dieser krieg sanktionen oder durch
verhandlungen alleine entschieden wird
ist glaube ich tatsächlich ist wäre
schuldig aber es würde nicht sagen es
ist eine ganz einfache frage die ich
noch mal stellen darf vielleicht um sie
zu kontextualisiert wer hat wen
überfallen die russin die ukraine oder
gar keine andere wahl hätten überhaupt
niemand
überfall auf den sender gleiwitz noch
einmal nein
das gute als die schuld daran sein dass
die überfallen werden
das hat genau das getan das hat konnte
schon realisieren sind unsinnig ist ein
brief selbst ist eher dass ein schultes
gerne sachen für mich ausreden aber ich
habe ja gar nicht so ich kann nur sagen
sie mich reden geben sie mir eine
wortspende
also ich hab ja und nochmals nach 24
stunden gesagt habe oder was weiß ich
also etwas gesagt habe die älteren
erinnern sich sicher
ich bin froh dass dieser brief in der
welt ist weil er gewisse dinge geklärt
weil es viele leute dieser republik gibt
die viele tendenzen dieses briefes
teilen das ist gut dass wir darüber
reden ich teile viele tendenz in diesem
brief nicht es muss ich auch klar sagen
aber es ist gut dass er in der
öffentlichkeit ist die beiden punkte die
mich vor allem stören wenn ich das sagen
darf ist zum einen ist klang eben schon
kurz an dass es einmal heißt der
berechtigte widerstand gegen einen
aggressor stehe in einem unerträglichen
missverhältnis zu dem leid dass man
produziere wenn man waffen liefere so
ein wenig den eindruck als würde man in
der ukraine nicht erweckt stark den
eindruck als ob mit der ukraine sagen
irgendwann ist mal gut mit dem
widerstand das finde ich natürlich sehr
paternalistisch von außen das geht
überhaupt nicht wenn eine nation sich
entschlossen hat lieber stehend zu
sterben als kind zu leben dann ist das
eine entscheidung die man erst mal
akzeptieren muss und das zweite und das
hat viel für die waffenlieferungen herr
kessler ich bin fit ich bin nicht für
endlose waffen liefern geht es momentan
muss man der ukraine waffen liefern und
man kann ihn nicht vorschreiben was sie
bedienen können und was sich also das
geht einfach nicht wenn wir an der seite
der ukraine stehen darf das nicht
folgenlos rhetorik werden müssen sie mit
waffen jetzt unterstützen klar und der
zweite punkt ist wir dürfen nicht
zulassen dass ist leider gottes auch
verbreitet dass wir putin ein motiv zu
einem gegebenenfalls verbrecherischen
hanseln liefern da wird natürlich auch
sagen er putin braucht gar keine motive
er handelt ja verbrecherisch spätestens
seit dem überfall wenn ich vorher schon
durch seine aktionen in der ukraine den
souveräner staat ist und dieses narrativ
zu übernehmen nach dem motto wir dürfen
den russischen bären nicht reizen dann
schlägt der umsicht und macht ganz
schlimme dinge wenn er einmal aus der
höhle heraus ist er ist so längst aus
der höhle er ist nicht mehr an der kette
und sich zu sehr in den kopf dieses
mannes hineinzubegeben und jeden schritt
zu verlassen der ihn noch mehr reizen
könnte obwohl er sich bereits als jemand
erwiesen hat der eher rational zu
handeln im stande ist das halte ich also
für zu viel mit füllung zu viel
einfühlung und deshalb für nicht
vernünftig dass werden das ist ein
endlager frage und zwar hier gab es ja
den vergleich von herr bruder auch
zwischen putin und hitler würden sie da
auch mitgehen häcksler dass man das
vergleichen gelöscht das könnte hier
unterrichten
also gehen sogar noch weiter ich bin
generell kein freund von von hitler
vergleichen also ich würde jetzt keinen
ich würde keinem dazu raten weil was ist
das für eine erkenntnis stiftende
kategorie werden gar keine also ich rate
generell von von von hitler vergleichen
ab ist jedes böse hat in sich seine
eigene maß an deren wertigkeit und man
muss versuchen das böse jeweils
aktuellen die schranken zu weisen er
hilft uns überhaupt nichts mehr sagen
bin ich aber ähnlich wie hitler das ist
nicht das was meine deutschen obsession
zu tun und hitler ist nicht so dass gut
die matif böse ist auch die benchmark
für das böse überhaupt der massenmord
und der völkermord fängt für uns bei 6
millionen an alles darunter sind
ordnungswidrigkeiten alles drunter
bekommt von uns den rat sich nicht zu
verteidigen sie würden wahrscheinlich
auf den leuten im warschauer ghetto den
rat gegeben haben herr broder recht zu
kämpfen um die opferzahlen nicht zu
erhöhen ihr standpunkt ist sowas von
unmoral nicht sowas von unanständig
selbstsüchtig mit einem einzigen wort
national aber eher oder sogar sehr gern
von ihnen so titulieren ich sage noch
einmal wenn ein krieg nicht beendet wird
dann gibt es interessen und diese
interessen sind jenseits des gemetzels
was da vor ort stattfindet ja mario pohl
und so weiter ich gucke mir die bilder
auch an und ich bin entsetzt ich habe
zufällig auch zwei söhne 28 und 30 und
ich möchte wieder nicht sehen ich bin
tatsächlich ihres möchten natürlich
nicht aber ich möchte einfach nur mal
sagen dass ich irritiert bin dass ich in
der bundesrepublik 2022 einem land das
sich einem friedens narrativ europa
angeschlossen hat 70 jahre frieden auf
diesem kontinent auf einmal binnen zehn
wochen ein kriegsgeheul und gerade zu
einer kriegs lust verspüren muss ja wenn
ich in die berichterstattung gucke dass
wir wenn ich in den spiegel schaue
bundesrat wirklich rede davon dass wir
zwei lernen
dass wir ihn von dem ersten moment an wo
ich erleben muss dass wir auf einmal ein
sondervermögen haben für 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr auf einmal alles über
den berg gekippt haben was mal eine
staatsraison dieses landes war nämlich
militärische zurückhaltung dass wir
keine waffen liefern in kriegsgebiete
ich gucke auf die grünen und frage mich
nur was ist aus dieser partei geworden
man kann also dass gegen ihn wollte
genau aber die grünen sind gewachsen und
im september noch mit plakaten von
annalena baerbock keine waffen in
kriegsgebiete das heißt wir haben hier
einen massiven verrat europäischen
werten ich würde das gern einmal
thematisieren und damit sage ich nicht
wissen das und damit sage ich nicht dass
wir darüber nachdenken müssen wir den
ukrainern helfen aber ob wir ihn mit
schwerem gerät helfen das ist die frage
die auf dem tisch liegt was überhaupt
unsere ziele sind das können wir nicht
so richtig definieren und das ist das
was ich vertrete hero sind 70 jahre
europa frieden jahren eine meine vision
ist schön dass ich negativ genannt haben
schlimmer wäre es gewesen sie hatten
realität genannt und es ist tatsächlich
nicht mehr als einnahme von ass genau
das problem das auch in ihrem brief zum
ausdruck kommt deswegen ist er so gut
dass ja ich habe ein unterschied das
versprechen wie es meine in alice
schwarzers brief und und dem brief der
der unterzeichner dass man im grunde ein
narrativ eine vision ein wunschdenken
zur realität erklärt das ist eins der
großen dilemma deutsche aber auch
mitteleuropäischer politik seit langem
dass man die realität schlicht
ausblendet die dna der menschen hat sich
aber nicht geändert und kriege werden
werden und wurden und denken sie bitte
auch an den gern in der öffentlichkeit
nicht so sehr thematisierten bei krank
krieg kriege werden die ganze zeit
geführt vor unseren augen unter und
übrigens kann
2000 von allen und sogar hören von allen
bürgern auf mich gewartet
die amerikaner sind meine weiß bisher
was ist überhaupt die sind wir haben
einfach aushalten und wir wissen ja dass
das problem ist das ist nicht richtig
das schaffen wir froh dass ich bringe
steht wollte mir ist uns aber überhaupt
kein verständnis dafür dass wir mit
diesem brief letztlich auch einer
öffentlichkeit in diesem land
suggerieren das ist diese möglichkeit
die sie dort ja noch nicht mal konkret
beziehen sondern nur wünschen dass es
die aktuell überhaupt gibt an dass man
so den frieden und gar die freiheit
erhalten kann ich weiß was ich in much
elite reden wir haben das ist jahr in
europa auge jährigen sie freiheit es
gibt die europäischen werte nicht sind
wir uns bei fragen wie dem die
migrations verhalten sind für uns bei
frage wie dem asylrecht sind wir uns
beim sozialstaat sind wir uns bei fragen
von religion und familie einig wir haben
in den ländern keinen konsens und noch
weniger debatte leider wir haben im
grenzübergreifenden europa schon gar
nicht sonst muss man definieren ist die
europäische realität polnisch oder ist
sie deutsch oder ist die ungarisch oder
ist die französisch also dieser art gibt
es jemand hält kurz nur ein hagel gern
sie hätten sie gern aber sie gibt es in
dieser frage nicht in allen anderen
zwischenfragen auf diesem kontinent
allem auch nicht ich sage nochmal wir
hatten 70 jahre frieden auf diesem
kontinent und diejenigen die gestern
noch die freiheit abgeschafft haben um
leben zu retten wollen jetzt leben
riskieren eine interessante in die
elektrische kurzschlüsse aus dem park
aussehen ungarn hause in polen aus es
immer schwierig und deswegen habe ich
vor über die friedliche revolution und
ihr oprah winfrey und mein ganzes
lebenswerk sind 30 jahre arbeit an der
europäischen integration und dann ever
closer juni in die seeleute geräte die
qualität finden gleich
sagen was noch eine andere obszönität
ist die sich hier in großer gelassenheit
wo das wort ob senioren einmal sonst
nein ich lasse es nicht außerdem las
dass kontextualisierung habe ich ja
schon vielen dank ich hab was sagt ich
würde eigentlich ihrem eingang kommenden
abenden konnten risikolos hier
verbreitet werden weil leute wie sie
hier viele jahrzehnte unter dem schutze
der amerikaner lebt und alles was ihnen
einfällt zu amerika ist das amerika ein
paar kriege gestartet hat seine fahnen
schreiben ja nach ihrem einverständnis
vielleicht ein paar zu wenige uni habe
sei man überhaupt nicht dass er sich nur
sagen will ist
gemacht ich wollte die schläuche nur
einmal begraben da darf ich dann sagen
zwei drittel der kriege die nach 1949
geführt worden sind von amerika
ausgegangen ist können sie nachlesen das
sind zahlen statistische zahlen so das
einzige was ich sage die kriege haben
wir nicht gesehen wir sind nicht bei
bagdad gewesen um die iraker gegen
amerika zu verteidigen wir sind auch
nicht so komme ich sonst nur für kinder
sowie konstantin wecker aber da wie auch
immer von kabul und dem desaster das ist
ja erst im september gewesen will ich
gar nicht wissen was der andere denkt
blenden ja ganz egal ob syrien jemen und
so weit haben immer ausgeblendet jetzt
ist es in der ukraine und nur weil es in
der ukraine ist wird es derart eskaliert
bis hin zu der eskalation ich sage es
noch mal dass wir inzwischen tatsächlich
denken wir könnten kalkuliert an den
nuclear
eskalation in kauf nehmen ich finde das
einfach so
machen
sie nichts
wofür ich werbung brauchen wir sind
gleich wieder zurück nach einer ganz
kurzen unterbrechung bis gleich massiv
gesucht
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bald 85 köpfen sind meinungen von
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt ärgert freut oder
schockiert
so nicht privat jet buschi hergiswil
wetten dass ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen hier einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der afg zu übergangen lasst
den leuten spaß wir sehen ja etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dürfte sein dass ich wegen eines quasi
zum manko vielleicht einmal kurz
doch das ist übliche an dem radträger
ausdrücken ich habe meinen beifall über
eine sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand gibt es bei den anderen
ist er ganz knapp drüber sprechen das
einfach nicht fertig richtig wo ist die
aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
solange es meine toleranz ich mein
programm zurück bei vielen nach schönem
sind wir wollen jetzt direkt mit der
frage weiter machen ob meine gäste von
der gefahr eines dritten weltkrieges
überzeugt sind denn das haben wir heute
noch zu wenig gesprochen da möchte ich
direkt bei hairkiller starten denn immer
wenn wir über die ukraine reden und über
russland als aggressor ist endlich auch
immer die frage was könnte es für
deutschland bedeuten und diese angst
bewegt dieses land wie hoch schätzen sie
denn die chancen dass putin den dritten
weltkrieg ausgelöst naja ich hoffe dass
er diese chance an sich vorbeigehen
lässt also ist zwischen ehren risiko als
eine chance
es ist sein narrativ ist seine erzählung
er droht und la france drohen mit der
atombombe wir kennen aus dem kalten
krieg das gleichgewicht des schreckens
besteht darin jetzt der heiß dass genau
die jetzt wieder heiß ist aber das
gleichgewicht des kalten krieges bestand
darin dass die andere seite ihnen damit
auch tun kann also ich glaube wenn man
sehr die gefahr sehe ich eben sowohl in
diesem brief als auch in manchen
debatten wenn man zu dogmatisch zu
leisetreter risch auf nach dem motto oh
gott oh gott der andere kann was ganz
ganz schlimmes tun als müssen wir uns
alle in die höhle zurückziehen und
gucken hoffen dass das ungewitter über
unseren köpfen dahin zieht und wer
wieder trockenen fußes in die friedens
ära hinaus gehen können das halte ich
für gefährlich das heißt die gefahr
einer eskalation in zum atomkrieg ist da
aber ich würde auf gar keinen fall jetzt
hier eins zu eins für bare münze dieses
szenario von herrn putin nehmen ich
würde mich da wirklich nicht ins
bockshorn jagen lassen im zweifelsfalle
kann auch frankreich als atommacht
russland vernichten als was könnt ihr
dann hat man sagen die
wahrscheinlichkeit gibt es dann gebe
aber ich sehe es weder morgen noch
übermorgen diese selbstmörderischen
aktion wird sich letzten endes auch
keine russische führung jetzt überlegen
die frage ist nur ob man einschalten
dieses spiel und die eine seite sagt ich
tue und die andere seite sagt ich habe
angst und lass mich von dieser drohung
ins bockshorn jagen lassen das ist
glaube ich die gefahr dass man zu sehr
zum büttel wird der propaganda von herrn
putin wenn man diese drohung sehr ernst
nimmt letzten endes spielt er genauso
mit der vernichtung russlands wenn man
die drohungen ernst haben wie eben auch
die vernichtung des westens eingepreist
sein müsste in dem russischen ärzten
szenario das heißt da müssen wir uns von
frei machen von diesen szenarien und
wenn er das half der in euch sogar
zur exegese verstiegen hat in herrn
hitler sei jüdisches blut zu finden also
wenn man die güte der verheißungen von
herrn lawrow für bare münze nimmt dann
glaube ich dann sind wir wirklich also
im phantasialand oder in der geisterbahn
also wirklich das als szenario nehmen
und ein wort noch zur eskalation
momentan eskaliert natürlich herr putin
ganz massiv also der kriegstreiber ist
herr putin und das sollte natürlich auch
bei allen historischen exkursen die wir
selbst wenn dich führen können nicht in
relativierende absicht hinzufügen also
nicht der ist deeskalierend ist nicht
herr steingart oder sonst jemand der
sagt wir müssen die ukraine bewaffnet
eskalierend ist momentan anzuheben sagte
putin um das auch noch mal ganz deutlich
auch für alle zuhörer und freilingen für
einen bruder zu sagen wenn ich dabei das
unterschreibe ich völlig ja und trotzdem
ist natürlich so eine sprechtag 6 also
dieses der dritte weltkrieg und dann
dieses eingreifen weil wir müssen in den
dritten weltkrieg um ihn zu verhindern
das sind natürlich sprechakte also ich
glaube schon dass man sich auch in so
eine sache hineinsteigern kann und das
wollte ich gar nicht sagen der einzige
satz den ich machen möchte ist vorüber
mir zu wenig nachgedacht wird und ich
sitze hier wirklich als jemand der
fundamental eigentlich seit 30 jahren
darauf worte dass europa sich als
kontinent emanzipiert das war 1989 die
absicht das flotte hat den großartigen
aufsatz geschrieben falls europa wacht
wir wollten nach 89 eine neue
friedensordnung der kalte krieg war vor
über das war eigentlich die absicht ja
und ich habe das gefühl dass wir jetzt
im grunde das alles abräumen und das
aber in dieser frage die amerikanischen
und die europäischen interessen nicht
kongruent sind wenn ich mir angucke was
jede form des krieges und der eskalation
für europa bedeutet also die sozialen
verwerfungen europa ist doch schon
ist es sehr unterschiedlich aber wie
auch immer das nuclear fallout wenn es
welche geben würde wäre hier und nicht
auf detroit und new york das heißt wir
haben doch ganz andere interessen patina
30 sieht fliegen können ja das hat er
ganz klar gesagt ja wir sind das
battlefield und dessen nochmal zu den
begriff dritter weltkrieg ja auch der
erste und der zweite weltkrieg waren
letztendlich europäische kriege die
haben hier stattgefunden mit ein
bisschen in der sahara und ein bisschen
in japan aber weltkrieg heißt eigentlich
ist das battlefield ja wir sind ein
bisschen unter bis die parole sinn wenn
ein kontinent leidet dann ist es dieser
kontinent deswegen möchte ich noch nie
gehört das ja und deswegen möchte ich
sagen in einem krieg wenn man ihn nicht
beendet gibt es in essen und die
interessen sind woanders zu suchen ja es
gibt ja auch viele theorien wenn sie
einmal ins internet gehen dass das
natürlich ein proxy krieg ist ja china
amerika was auch immer da ausgefochten
wird ein amerikanischer oder chinesische
vorherrschaft wie auch immer und
deswegen müssen wir doch wenn wir jetzt
mal ge und umgebung strategisch
nachdenken noch mal fragen worum geht es
hier was ist das ziel wer verdient an
diesem krieg wer will ihn beenden der
regel durch spurwechsel und
sein ich war schneiden wir sehen ist ein
gutes stichwort herr bruder wie können
wir denn den krieg wenn wir können den
trick überhaupt nicht beenden haben ihn
nicht angefangen den krieg beenden kann
nur putin in dem er seine jungs
zurückruft und zwar möglichst bald und
möglichst in gänze und er würde damit
auch vieler russischer leben inzwischen
retten und ich weiß überhaupt nicht nur
her hier in diesem lande dieses
verständnis für putin kommt vergessen
sie mal ukraine schauen sie sich nur an
was putin mit seinem eigenen land macht
wie er die meinungsfreiheit behandeln
wir bürger eingebracht werden soll darum
gehen wo er reicht das schon um mir
einen regime change in moskau zu
wünschen dazu hat er nicht der ukraine
über fallen müssen aber ihre aufregung
und die ihre freunde und diesen
menschlichen brief unterzeichnet haben
geht um den punkt dass wir imstande
wären einen dritten weltkrieg zu
verhindern
wir sind bei ständer wir haben dann
vielleicht nicht alle ihre fantastische
wo der glauben einzeltäter weltkrieg
könnte kommen wenn man sollte der verein
mitten im dritten weltkrieg bereit sind
einen weltkrieg muss nicht so romantisch
anfangen wieder erster weltkrieg mit dem
attentat von sarajewo wir sind mit einem
dritten weltkrieg und damit mit anderen
mitteln ausgetragen im cyber findet er
längst statt und es geht jetzt einfach
um die frage wo ungleichen dieser dritte
weltkrieg war wer geht da gerade gegen
ende im glück gibt es keine
planungssicherheit ich weiß nur dass wir
jetzt ein krieg kamen dahinter geht weiß
ich nicht also ich hab sie und streckt
general karl oder nicht gesehen das
wusste gerne paulus bei steilen gehört
auch nicht wie es enden würde also ich
sehe einen russisch-ukrainischen krieg
aber noch keinen dritten weltkrieg wo
sehen sie den schön dass ich nicht
segeln aufgehen aber wenn sie sagen sie
sehen ihn schon wirklich wissen wo sie
denn sehen hier können nachher privat
ist das okay jetzt gut vielleicht ist
die aufregung die die axa beklagt und
die der brief aber letztlich bin ich
kein glück marica war war warum
kaprizieren wir uns als wir finden
hinter vergleiche problematisch richtig
wir sollten auch mit der vokabel
weltkrieg finde ich an der stelle ein
bisschen vorsichtiger umgehen also wir
haben einen massiven konflikt und ich
vermute dass sie auch mal im cyber
einflussnahme auf einen möglichen enden
an spielen wir haben genau genommen viel
zu lange europäisch ignoriert
einflussnahme in china ist auf europa
auf die amerikanische auf das mache ich
auf den südamerikanischen auf dem
pazifischen raum also wir haben seine
herrschaft ansprüchen von aggressoren
überall auf der welt genau interessiert
uns vor allen dingen deshalb auch sie
persönlich ja gesagt weil es vor unserer
haustür stattfindet die richtig ja aber
wenn wir unabhängig davon was für die
ukraine attestieren rich attestieren uns
einig sind dass sie lieber feinden sind
dass wir den krieg in der tat nicht
selbst beenden können weil putin
begonnen hat und wenn uns aber
vollkommen klar ist dass wir nicht
tatenlos zusehen wollen wie putin voran
marschiert im übrigen lange angekündigt
mit einer großen zustimmung in seinem
eigenen land versehen mit einer
propaganda der mutter beim brand ihrer
zu seiner situation ahl und jeder der
die ddr und russische propaganda zu ddr
zeiten erlebt hat und ich habe als kind
und jugendliche noch sehr gut in meinem
ohr und ich habe in russland selbst
erlebt wie das regime sich nicht
geändert hat der kann nicht im unklaren
darüber sein wie putin aber therapie
wurde lernte sich denn wir kleine
zwischenrang man sich live wie erklären
sie sich denn dann die enge ihrer ex
partei der afg zu russland hier auch sie
mit den linken das gemeinsame haus hat
ein grund warum ist eine ex partei ist
es beantwortet die frage das ist denn
daran ja da italien
ich war einmal vorsitzende aber diese
art von politik die sie heute betreibt
und nicht nur zum thema wusste noch
zugang seit 2010 zum weiher eindruck
frage ich nicht mit das wird immer gern
interpretiert dass ich in russland war
und dass sich personen dort getroffen
habe die heute immer noch putins nähe
sind und wie ein sehr eigenes bild
machen durfte das unter anderem dazu
beiträgt dass ich heute genau den
standpunkt vertreten die ich hier heute
abend vertreten das hat seine gründe und
ich kann aus meiner eigenen persönlichen
erfahrung sagen russland damals noch
sowjetunion zu ddr zeiten hat sich nicht
geändert es hat mir eine demokratische
phase gegeben da war der feudalismus
sache war der kommunismus heute haben
wir putins regime und das hat natürlich
auf die menschen in diesem riesigen land
natürlich auswirkungen gehabt das heißt
einen regime change putin weg wurde noch
nicht immer viel bewirken denn wir
wissen dass die zustimmung zu putins
großmachtpolitik groß ist zumindest so
groß dass es ihnen weiter oder sommer
kritiker seiner couleur weiter an der
macht halten wird das heißt das einzige
ziel kann darin bestehen seinen
vormarsch zu begrenzen und das werden
wir kister da bin ich bin ich bei ihnen
das werden wir nicht über jahre und
jahrzehnte führen können trotzdem muss
uns auch klar sein dass dieser krieg in
drei wochen nicht vorbei sein wird es
wird also noch eine weile gehe und die
frage die wiener entscheiden können
helfen wir den überfallenen tun was
nicht und da ist meine antwort ganz
können wir auch an einen sozusagen
russland ohne putin oder nach putin uns
vorstellen ein demokratisches russland
auf dass wir hin wirken wollten es gab
also bei allem was sie aufgezählt haben
sozusagen die langen phasen des
russischen totalitarismus ja gab es
immerhin mal die faser nach 89 wo wir es
versucht haben das hat ungefähr zehn
zwölf jahren gedauert da wollten wir
etwas anderes putin stand vor dem
bundestag es gab standing ovations wären
eine kfz ordnung wir hatten zumindest
die absicht das live glaube schon ein ja
so aber diese phase ist schief gelaufen
da müsste man mal analysieren warum
eigentlich ja werte eigentlich was
gewollt und so weiter nur die firma
recom was auch immer jedenfalls zu
fragen ist doch immer noch was ist die
friedensordnung die wir danach wollen
und diese frage stelle ich mir natürlich
mehr wirklich aber ist das nicht ein
bisschen sie sagen ganz ganz weit in der
wenn wir jetzt sagen hier erstmal ganz
realistische russia 3 also ich frage
mich was ist denn das jetzt für eine
strategie wenn wir sagen russland muss
total ausgetrocknet wäre total ja das
war nicht besorgt natürlich
niemand gesagt habe ich nicht gehört
hatte hier in dieser runde
drei auf völliges ökonomisches
sozusagen die sanktionen auch niemals
erreichen da sind etwas ist ein quadrat
es nicht funktioniert dann heute auch
nicht das ist genau die frage um die es
jetzt geht ja deswegen geht es ja um die
frage ob wir fracking gas bekommen oder
den gashahn zudrehen und so weiter und
so weiter trotzdem würde ich noch immer
noch mal darauf hinwirken wollen dass
wir ein kontinent sind jedoch einen also
eine eurasischen friedens entwurf hat da
könnte doch nicht sagen dass wir jetzt
die mauer die wir 89 hatten geht aus
einer guten einigung lager hinein
inzwischen trage ganz mehr menschen über
die neue ordnung sprechen nach
infusionen ist die frage aktuell 80
prozent der russen in russland sind ja
für putin da kommt natürlich die frage
auch gerne an sie beide können wir jetzt
gerade überhaupt schon darüber
nachdenken was nach putin basiert und
wie wir mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten
werden egal was nach gut es ist ganz
ganz schwierig aber da bin ich ja dabei
ja also die frage ist ja wir glauben ja
immer oder zumindest es gibt es einige
die glauben dass wenn wir jetzt
sozusagen hart genug mit putin sind dass
wir dann die opposition gegen putin in
russland eigentlich mobilisieren ja das
halte ich auch tatsächlich für
unrealistisch und ich glaube dass wir
das gegenteil tun dass je mehr wir putin
sozusagen in die enge treiben desto mehr
wird der brutto faschismus der oder
nationalismus denn da unterwegs ist weil
putin sich dann da ist ja meinungs-
unterdrückung gebe ich ihnen ja völlig
recht dann stellt sich als meine nur in
absolut so bin ich auch dabei und desto
mehr wird man dann natürlich wird putin
sich hinstellen können seht was der west
mit mehr macht und wird im prinzip genau
diese freien abschieben lassen doch
nicht besser ihn machen zu lassen
ist irgendwie gar nichts sie füttern das
krokodil in der hoffnung gewerbe sie als
letzten fressen sie prügeln und glauben
mit immer mehr prügeln gibt es weniger
nein nein nein ich habe die prügel nicht
angefangen wissen sie es ist jetzt eine
art von wegscheide wer es ist der moment
der in münchen 38 stattfand als hitler
genau wusste und dafür gleich ganz
bewusst dass man ihm alles durchgehen
lässt und wenn der nächste china mit der
atombombe droht wenn alle europäischen
länder ihre beziehungen zu taiwan nicht
abbrechen wenn der tee run auf die idee
kommt wieder atombombe zu drohen wenn
die europäische union ihre beziehungen
mit israel nicht einstellt dann wird das
das ergebnis unserer tage wie der marder
panzern design strahlengang nach china
oder die parallel dahin ja ist denn dann
unsere strategie also sagen wir bleiben
wir mal bei diesem china taiwan finde
ich total interessant ja also china
entscheidet sich jetzt auch wir
schnappen uns mal gerade teil waren
sie sind kurz davor so was machen wir
dann fahren wir mit marder panzern jeder
auch gewinne lassen wir gewähren solange
die wir hier unser bier in ruhe trinkt
aber dann sind wir uns ja nicht
eine frage und die spd eintreten dass
mit ihnen eigentlich sein aber er wurde
im prinzip möglich eine einer tragen und
die kamera aus
aber ich möchte ich eine eine sache
fragen sie sie sagen ja dass das wir
kämpfen müssen und da sagen was wirklich
meine sprache spricht sie würden also
nicht für die ukraine dann selbst in den
krieg ziehen aber die schweren waffen
altersbedingt in gar keinen trick man
sie vielleicht nur in einen krieg für
ein besseres klima aber nein das ist
nicht der punkt der punkt am ende punkt
ist dass wir jetzt ein diktator
ermächtigen mit einem anderen land zu
verfahren wie er will und dass mit
diesem überfallenen rand das recht
absprechen sich zu verteidigen
und
doch genau dass man wieder müssen der aa
wenn wir ja sagen müssen wir auch b
sagen das heißt wenn wir jetzt die
ukraine zudem den gewinn auch weiter
unterstützen und es kommt dann doch dazu
müssten sie ja eigentlich sagen ich wäre
auch bereit das dann auch deutschland
mit zieht in den krieg sonst weil sonst
müssen wir ja immer nur hoffen dass
putin nichts macht oder sehe ich das
falsch wir sehen das absolut falsch
absolut die bezweifeln aber dass putin
das nicht tun würde ich glaube was ich
glaube es völlig irrelevant aber in der
tat glaubt nicht dass es tun wird der
mann hat eine yacht die 500 millionen
euro gekostet hat er hat mehrere sehr
wertvolle immobilien und zwar nicht in
berlin wilmersdorf sondern einen ganz
anderen location ich glaube dass der
mann fiel zu satt und viel zu fett und
viel zu zufrieden und viel zu reich ist
um einen atomaren niedergang zu
riskieren aber er weiß genau dass er mit
dieser drohung im westen erfolg haben
kann und bereits ein erfolg hat und ich
glaube vielleicht verzeihung das ist
auch anfänger wir haben sehr sehr
theoretisch über krieg gewinnen oder zu
einem ende führen geräte damit
tatsache ist doch dass jetzt schon die
ukraine die letztlich in der
erwartungshaltung viel schwächer
gestartet ist militärisch als die russen
inzwischen sich mit seiner einer
russischen armee die auf massive
verluste erlitten hat de facto nicht in
allen details aber de facto einen
stellungskrieg wir dass wir reden bei
allem respekt vor militärischen
eskalationen wir reden über eine
russische armee die so weit hinter allen
internationalen erwartungen zurück
geblieben ist weil es nämlich massive
defizite massive defizit ist die vereine
ist dann nicht zu gewinnen egal wie oft
man jahre krieg ist immer krieg da sehe
ich nicht so krieg ist immer furchtbar
aber jetzt vor einem pulli und einer
kaputten russischen armee
zurückzuweichen den ukrainern zu
empfehlen das zu tun das wäre als würde
ich uns alle lieder militärisch
hingucken sagen da ist nichts zu
gewinnen die russische armee ist in
einer solchen ober macht das selbst wenn
wir den ukraine an waffen geben so
verändert haben dass
die sanierung der ukraine und dann haben
wir auf die nächsten zehn jahren wird
und was auch immer
ein paar kisten
über die lösung gesehen wo sich alle
hier sehr uneinig kann man sagen
wenn sie das alles jetzt hier hören was
ist ihre ansicht
kontroverse solange sie friedlich ist
gut insofern schön dass wir uns streiten
aber was ich wirklich also gefährlich
mache ich nicht das wort aber was ich
für nicht zielführend halte ist wenn man
sich zu sehr in das kochen den kopf
versucht hineinzuversetzen dieses
aggressors also was hat denn putin jetzt
sich überlegt was könnte er sich als
nächstes überlegen wenn wir dies oder
jenes nicht machen ich finde eigentlich
es geht doch zunächst einmal ganz
einfach darum den einfachen satz hat
herr scholz ausgesprochen am ersten mai
in düsseldorf unser bundeskanzler
russland hatte der ukraine nichts zu
suchen das klingt jetzt sehr simpel aber
das zunächst mal die grundlage aller
debatten die wir führen russland hat in
der ukraine nicht zu suchen egal was in
der geschichte zurückgehen russland hat
heute nichts in der ukraine zu suchen
der zweite punkt ist die ukraine sendet
hilferuf an uns an den westen auch und
besonders in deutschland wie gehen wir
mit diesen hilfen
aber wir haben sie nicht hinreißen wir
haben sie nicht hinreichend wir haben
teilweise lächerlich gemacht mit den
schutzhelmen von von der
ukraine
schon wieder zu unterbrechen und das ist
auch jetzt nicht der zeitpunkt ist jetzt
zu sagen schon wir haben als deutschland
genug getan ich glaube wir haben stand
heute nicht genug getan kein
blankoscheck für die nächsten jahre
hinein aber jetzt nicht wieder sozusagen
einen schönen lenz zu machen in
anführungszeichen und zu sagen also wir
haben eure wunschliste eingedampft das
kriegt ja jetzt und jetzt die nächsten
monate machen wir erstmal eine friedens
sich an den massnahmen eigenen land
unterhalten uns über die ziele die wir
verfolgen ich kann momentan hat die
ukraine ein anrecht auf nicht nur
rhetorische unterstützung was das genug
dass das werden wir im gang ist im gang
des weges sehen wir jetzt zurück legen
aber momentan kommt ist glaube ich
darauf an die militärische unterstützung
bis zu einem punkt zu führen denn sie
bisher glaube ich nicht so im blick
haben bis zu einem punkt an dem es
möglich ist die russen in eine
verhandlungssituation zu zwingen das ist
noch möglich das ist die frage ich denke
schon ich würde noch nicht nachhaltig
habe in den damals das ist glauben ist
das hochland er verhandelte stärker ist
auftritt und die geringer der widerstand
ist auf dem das trifft das glaube ich
nicht so und dann liegt die frage genau
wo ist dieses genug und wo ist dieser
punkt ja und können wir den kalkulieren
und so weiter und so weiter und wieviel
mario puls und buddhismus es bis dahin
geben das ist die frage die wir
diskutieren ja und diese werde ja nicht
entscheidend wie wir uns anstrengen
werden
immerhin wir durch die arge schon mal
eingegrenzt ja also das ist ja schon mal
relativ vernünftig ja zu sagen die
grenzen weil diese frage ein und
trotzdem ist ja um dieses genug ist ja
ein wirklich sehr dehnbarer begriff und
die fragen von radio entschieden wer in
deutschland öffentlich sehr wichtig muss
demokratisch entschieden werden nicht
durch meinungsumfragen leider auch nicht
durch diskussionsrunden will sondern
eben im moment gar nicht am ende doch
keiner wie weit sie bereit sind zu gehen
ja aber im tor stehen tatsächlich als
zuschauer dabei aber die verantwortung
die deutschland hat muss auf
demokratischen leben das heißt im
bundestag entschieden werden dann möchte
ich wirklich noch daran erinnern das ist
keine petitesse nicht meinungsumfragen
können sagen wir machen jetzt also
machen gar nix das muss demokratisch
entschieden gehört nicht viel ein die
möglichkeit wissen sie wir können nichts
machen und wir wollen keine truppen
hinderten und unsere
eingriffsmöglichkeiten geben könnte
die branche die bundeswehr fliegt und es
wird bundeswehr kommen wir abschaffen
ist eine friedens armee und auch mit 100
milliarden wird sie nicht wieder
auferstehen die bundeswehr integrieren
vielleicht ja russland für die haben
mehr das kann schon sein aber bei uns
versichert ist nicht und die russen
haben wir hier noch eine andere sichert
auch aber gast also wie viele ukraine
erwarten die bundeswehr ab also das
verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht der bruder
doch das ist ein komplizierter
wissen sie ich habe eine separate kabel
ein vorschlag kommt von einem dänischen
politiker das nahm ich glatt vergessen
habe aus den 70er jahren damals
vorgeschlagen die dänische armee
abzuschaffen stelle dänischen armee eine
telefonnummer hinzurichten die die
russen anrufen können und dann auf
russisch die botschaft zu geben lieber
russen wir haben soeben kapituliert und
wenn wir das machen ist dieser konflikt
vorbei für uns wird es aber auch gewisse
konsequenzen haben und die müssen sie
dann im kopf der bruder werden heute an
das letzte wort unsere sendung ist zu
ende das war ein spezial von 48 wie sie
vermutlich gemerkt haben denn das thema
ist so wichtig dass wir darüber einmal
monothematisch sprechen wollten morgen
abend sind wir dann wieder klassisch für
sie zurück ins schön haben nach machen
sie es gut
[Musik]